my name is Jason Daggett I live in
Portland Oregon I work for a company
named Galois we do kind of weird
interesting things maybe you've heard of
us we often work for government agencies
so this work was funded in part by a
ARPA ir po was interested in secure
computation in this context secure means
privacy preserving security in general
could mean many different things so I
ARPA they wanted to run a program on
secure computing and they didn't really
know what were the hard problems and
what were the easy problems in that
space so they hired us to sort of figure
out the low-hanging fruit and try to
solve those problems
so that when they put out the big
proposal they could they could ask for
more interesting offers from people I'm
gonna try to keep this talk fairly
high-level because some parts of it are
like deeply theoretical but I want to
make this you know as widely accessible
as possible and I also this is my first
time at strange loop so I don't really
know the backgrounds of people here but
I understand that most of you are
programmers I think the takeaway here
shouldn't be that we built a particular
system or a particular compiler and that
you can use it but more that we were
faced with a particular problem and we
used certain techniques and frameworks
to solve that problem I also need to
stress that what I'm presenting today is
a proof of concept most of the
components are open-source but I don't
have like a full like I don't have a URL
I can give you at the end of the talk I
can I can I will have URLs for some
parts of it so that you could go play
with it later if you want all right so I
think I guess the right place to start
is what is homomorphic encryption so a
homomorphism if you ask a mathematician
is it it's some sort of transformation
that preserves structure and in this
case the structure I want to preserve is
the ability to decrypt later so a
transformation then that I might be
interested in is given two integers that
are ciphertext how do you add those
together you know two in the normal way
to get a new cipher text that can be
decrypted and in the process the the
computer that adds them together isn't
allowed to eat isn't allowed to decrypt
them in the process they don't have the
private key and the way like the the
sort of abstraction that the the
homomorphic encryption community gave us
is this thing called rhythmatic circuits
and I'm not going to go too much into
the mathematics behind it but
mathematicians refer to this structure
as a ring so it's in this case so you
could pick lots of rings for efficiency
reasons we stuck to integer and
arithmetic operations on integers you
could also pick like a boolean ring so
the arithmetic operations we support our
addition and this is like normal
addition so it's associative which means
if you have three numbers you're adding
together and addition is binary so you
can add you know these two first and
then this one and that's the same as
adding the other two first and this one
it's commutative which means if you have
a plus B you can also add B plus a and
get the same result identity means that
zero does what you expect zero to do
there's also inverses so we have
subtraction in this case we also have
multiplication well all rings have
multiplication the thing that's
different in this case is our
multiplication is commutative which is
again that property that if you multiply
a times B versus B times a you'll get
the same result notice there's no
inverses though for multiplication so we
don't in general have division we have a
distributivity law which is just another
way of saying that addition and
multiplication interact the way you
expect there's nothing unusual or new to
learn there the the thing that I want to
like re-emphasize though is that all of
this happens on values that are
indistinguishable from from random noise
if you were to inspect during the
computation the two integers you're
adding or multiplying or whatever they
just look like noise but when you're all
done you can still decrypt it and
the the sort of the theory of Ag like
that's kind of all you get but there's a
little bit more sometimes so this will
come up again later in the talk but the
people we worked with the implementers
of the HP library that we used they came
up with kind of a clever hack to support
a restricted form of division in certain
cases like with some restrictions so
that's that's what I mean by sometimes a
bit more but but there's a lot of things
that you won't get out of this so
there's no control flow so there's no if
statements there's no memory
like there's nothing nowhere to store a
value or read a value from other than
you know variables will like your
ciphertext will be holding a value so
maybe it helps to give a little bit of
an example so this this is the actual
concrete syntax we use for specifying
our arithmetic circuits in this case the
first line says there's a wire named
zero and instan takes a it provides an
input which is a ciphertext
there's a wire named one which also has
a ciphertext and then there's a wire -
which is hard-coded to the constant
eight and then there's a wire coming out
of an of an addition gate and it takes
as inputs wires 1 0 and 2 and the
overall circuit could have multiple
outputs in general in this case it just
outputs whatever's on wire 3 but you
know all of that is is kind of kind of
kind of technical and theoretical what I
really want you to take away from these
arithmetic circuits and what the
homomorphic encryption is in this case
is that they're integer polynomials so
they have integer coefficients and the
variables take on integer values and and
that's that's really the intuition I
want you to have at this point and I I
think that's great I think it's great
that these are polynomials and I I don't
know if you think it's great polynomials
are really awesome to the point that
once in 2011 I posted this on math
overflow where I said I think
polynomials
one of the greatest inventions of
humankind not only are they extremely
flexible and come up in so many domains
of math but they've led to interesting
breakthroughs for example trying to find
the closed form solution of the quintic
polynomial led évariste Galois to lay
down the base theory that became group
theory which also is where we have rings
so polynomials are great I might be
biased you might have also noticed the
company I work for is named Galois after
that évariste Galois alright so
homomorphic encryption so now you kind
of know vaguely what it is so what's it
good for
now this one's a little bit harder for
me because I don't really know of any
sort of like I don't really know of any
applications where people are using it
in the wild so these are kind of a
little bit hypothetical but one example
I like to give people is trust is not
transitive so I might trust my doctor
but I don't necessarily trust everybody
my doctor trusts so let's say my doctor
has genomic data for me and my doctor
says well there's this maybe research
group or this company or something that
can do some sort of analysis using your
genome along with some other data sets
they have and they can predict you know
whether you might have certain diseases
and it's like oh well that's exciting
let's let's do that and so using a chi
you might encrypt your genomic data you
know your doctor then sends that to this
party that you don't necessarily trust
they're able to mix that with maybe some
other encrypted data from other people
do some number crunching send back the
result and your doctor can decrypt it
and then maybe tell you something about
your genome there's maybe some other
examples you can imagine with cloud
computing or something like that
[Music]
all right yeah so I also want to talk
about what are the problems with it
right so if a chi is so great why are we
not all using it already and as I
understand that there's at least two
problems with making it practical and
the first problem is bad performance and
when I say bad performance I mean
something like five to ten orders of
magnitude worse than just directly doing
the computation on your CPU right which
is which is a pretty big pretty big
difference the other problem which was
called out actually I can't remember who
specifically I'm not a cryptographer but
some well-respected cryptographer so
it's definitely called this one out
which is it's it's kind of hard to
program I mean I like polynomials but
maybe not everybody does yeah so what's
the big deal is fall no wheels all right
so so this is sort of my contrived
example this is I will show you how this
actually can work but let's do image
processing so this is kind of blown up
in huge but the source image was a 64 by
64 image and you want to go from before
to after so very simple sharpening
algorithm I'll let you decide whether
you would actually want to sharpen that
image so the question is you know what
what polynomial do you write down to
sharpen a 64 by 64 image and and we can
we can talk about a Julia program for
that so this is just a normal julia
program that will do the kind of image
sharpening i'm talking about so it has
this weight matrix which is a three by
three matrix for computing a weighted
sum of a neighborhood of each pixel in
the image and so then a little bit
further down is this for loop that goes
over the whole image - the the the
boundary of the image and then an inner
loop that actually computes that
weighted sum and we're going to write
all these new pixels to this image - and
there's also this kind of right shift
which I think I mentioned before there
was this like limited support for
division so
I'll get in the details about that a
little bit later but keep in mind it's
the last operation that we do on the
ciphertext if if if we were able to feed
in a ciphertext all right so so the
question again so now I've given you a
nice specification for the image
sharpening it should be really easy to
write down a polynomial right well a 64
by 64 image is going to have over 4,000
variables in it and it's also going to
lack all the structure that we had when
we had a Julia program right so the fact
that we were using a weighted
neighborhood you you won't be able to
see that in the polynomial so I guess I
guess the question is you know could we
get the computer to derive the
polynomial that we need from this
program and the answer turns out to be s
or else I wouldn't be here and and the
way that we did that was symbolic
execution and I'm gonna I'm gonna pause
for a minute to see if there's any
questions on slide oh just so we don't
get like a backlog of questions all
right let me hit refresh
all right I don't see any questions yet
all right so I want to I want to talk
about some bulk manipulation so if you
know this is a concrete math problem
right so five plus five plus three and
you get 13 but if you've if you've taken
maybe like high school algebra or
something like that you start using
letters right so then you have X plus X
plus 3 is 2 X plus 3 and you know that
if X is 5 you're gonna get 13 again so
we can get computers to do this and we
can also generalize it to programs and
not just expressions right so if we have
this if statement it's going to return a
when a and B are equal and when a is
greater than B it'll return B and
otherwise it'll return negative 1 so we
could boil that down into a set of
values and say that that statement in
the program really is like multivalued
and the way you would sort of naturally
represent this is maybe the like tuples
a set of tuples so this and the way you
would read this is returns a when a
equals B and B when a is greater than B
and negative 1 in the other case and I
kind of my conditions here a little
simplified because I carefully chose
this example so that if state the
branches of the a statement are disjoint
so symbolic execution is is basically
you build a you build a normal
interpreter for a programming language
and then you sort of generalize it with
symbolic manipulation like I was just
describing and it turns out to be very
powerful but also you quickly run into
the theoretical limits of computer
science if so this this bullet point is
a reference to that you know that if it
terminates so I can I can sort of
symbolically evaluate your program and
you've given me some known inputs and
some unknown inputs and it runs for a
while and gets but gets back an answer
and that answer is going to have all the
side effects removed because for all the
all the known values I'm able to
actually compute things
so side-effects are you know if though
if the program said well if your if your
matrix is too large then it's an error
well if we if we run it on something
with a small enough matrix then then we
know that is dead code for that run of
the program and so that side-effect of
like throwing an exception when the
matrix is the wrong size can just be
removed from the from the final thing we
output and so I like to think of this
final output as being a functional
specification of what that program would
have computed given those inputs
runtimes
are not great for symbolic execution
because you're basically running the
program you know when it has a symbolic
input you're sort of running the program
as if it were running on all values that
symbolic input could take plus you have
all of the normal execution overhead and
and the bookkeeping overheads so it's
it's sort of always going to be at least
as bad as if you just ran programs
concretely it's built on decades of
really interesting research you know ICF
P was going on here earlier this week
and it's maybe still going on and you
know those folks have contributed to
that kind of research and and I kind of
like to describe it as magical but a
friend of mine was like oh it's you know
if you say it's magical that that's kind
of bad because people are like but but I
wanted to stand it and and that's fair
I think it's magical but at his advice I
put in that you know it works
surprisingly well sometimes all right I
will I will check again for questions
maybe get some water
all right so now that I've given you
some background I'm gonna describe the
compiler that we built which again is a
proof of concept and I can't actually
give you the working compiler at the
moment we built it from since this was a
sort of like a lightweight investigation
that I are per wanted and we were just
building a proof of concept it was
really important for us to pick things
that already existed and fit them
together in an interesting way so we
used the Giulia programming language and
I'll get into more of why we picked that
but that's a nice open source language
probably folks in this room are familiar
with it we also used crucible which is a
symbolic evaluation framework that we
develop at Galois that's also open
source it's written in Haskell it's one
of the more complicated and interesting
Haskell code bases that I know of we
also use this library called palisade
palisade is how we do our rhe that's
developed by Kurt Roloff and his
graduate students at New Jersey
Institute of Technology in he refers to
it as a lattice cryptography library I'm
not a cryptographer so I that doesn't
mean much to me but maybe it does to you
all right so Julia it's open source
being open source is really nice to us
because it meant so when we first
started this project we didn't really
know how we were gonna solve this
problem and being able to dive into the
source code of Julia meant that if we
had any questions about how Julia works
we could answer them ourselves you know
there's a chance that we could ask also
ask the authors of the project and being
open source actually makes that even
easier because who has worked on it is
going to be public right we don't have
to have the point of contact at a
company or something like that
it was also nice that it targeted
scientific users so for our hypothetical
examples it made them more plausible
right because maybe that genomic example
I gave before maybe a data scientist
working in Julia came up with an
algorithm that they thought was
interesting it's it's actively
pained with a like a steadily growing
community it seems to be getting more
traction all the time that was
attractive to us we've used the 0.5
version of Julia because we started this
project about two two and a half years
ago at this point and I think that's the
version that was stable at the time and
then pretty quickly they moved to 0.6
and then in August they released 1.0 I
don't think anything in our work is
really tied to the specific version of
Julia that we used but it won't
immediately translate to the newer
version because we we just happen to
depend on a few internal details of
Julia at the moment all right
so Julia is a great language but it's
full of dynamic features you you can
statically write down types but for the
most part it's a dynamically typed
language
you know specs a heap a stack mutable
variables all this stuff and this is the
point where I joined the team I joined
the team after they had already been
working on it for about a month or two
and I almost quit the project because I
was like you guys are insane I don't
know how you're gonna solve this problem
you're doomed you know is moping around
the the lunch room at work going what
have I gotten myself into you know hey
Rob what do you think about this Rob's
one of my co-workers who developed
crucible and he's like you know this
sounds like a symbolic evaluation
problem it's like go on alright so yeah
his answer to me was try out crucible
and and just as a fun little factoid at
the time crucible already had a front
end called grackle which I'll have a
link to later in the slides which is
originally crucible was developed to do
symbolic simulation of MATLAB programs
so in the very very first few weeks when
we wanted to try out this idea we
actually pretended that MATLAB was Julia
alright so I'll talk a little bit about
like how you how you use our compiler so
you write a Julia program
the the one I showed you early on in the
talk the image sharpening program that
would be a suitable program then using
crucible you you feed your Giulia
program into crucible actually we have a
library that'll help you with this and
crucible will grind away on your program
and you need to tell it which inputs are
symbolic and which are concrete and then
if it terminates well you'll get back
from crucible is an arithmetic circuit
you'll also get back
well maybe I'll talk about that in a
minute there's a little bit of metadata
you'll also get back alright so then you
would take your take your data whatever
your you know your genomic data may be
or your image and you encrypt it using
palisade and then you you give your
cipher text and your thematic circuit to
palisade and you let it run for a while
and you know again this is five to ten
orders of magnitude slower than if you
did the computation directly and and
keep in mind we picked this integer ring
these integer polynomials because
they're more efficient so if you did
fully homomorphic encryption for example
the story would be even worse alright so
then you know more time that it took me
to describe that palisade will give you
back your answer it can actually be kind
of fast on some small inputs and then
you can decrypt your results and so like
that's that's like the full thing like
you know we we wrote a library in Julia
that does some of the orchestration for
you to make it easy to do some of these
steps like step number two step number
four and you know getting the answers
back that actually turns out to be a
little bit harder than you would not
harder a little more tedious than you
would like
so we automate that as well all right so
so when when you want to use crucible
for something so so you may remember I
said one of the things I wanted people
to go to this talk was this idea that
there's these tools and techniques out
there and that you might want to use
them at some point so I think it's
useful to talk a little bit about how
you would use crucible so crucible
internally has sort of a an imperative
programming language defined inside it
and it's at a pretty low level
where you've got basic blocks and you've
got different kinds of statements you've
got you've got arbitrary control flow
though which is maybe surprising
considering it's going to be doing this
complicated symbolic execution thing but
again it's just a generalization of
normal execution so you can just think
of it as an interpreter for a
programming language and it just so
happens that sometimes values are
variable and and not completely known
and so what we do is we reflect on your
julia program and we we get its ast and
then we can even ask the the julia the
standard julia compiler you know lower
this code for lower this code a bit so
you know D sugar it turn it into a bit
of a simpler intermediate language and
this was nice we we didn't have to write
a parser which I don't know if the Julia
folks have the justice yet but the last
time I checked they didn't have a parser
description outside of their own
implementation so you know this saved us
a bit of work trying to trying to
understand what their grammar was and we
didn't have to worry about bugs like we
weren't going to miss parse it we
weren't we didn't have to understand you
know we had this small budget we didn't
have to understand how they do sugar
programs so that saved this time it's
very very nice to be able to use
reflection in this way
but we take that program we we get the
ast and then we convert it to an S
expression which is that's just sort of
an implementation detail we could have
used to JSON or lots of other formats
and and then we give that that program
to crucible and then translating that
into crucible is fairly easy that all
happens in Haskell again to support
arbitrary control flow so you know
Julia's exceptions and whatnot are no
problem for us figuring out how to
support structured data was actually
harder and the reason that's harder is
because well well two reasons I guess
they're in the wrong order here because
the the first reason is you only get
integers to work
with that second bullet point and so if
you like if you have a matrix and you
want to you know send that to your
homomorphic encryption you know your
arithmatic circuit your polynomial you
can just flatten it out and keep track
of what shape it had like which elements
of that list go where and the matrix but
you know if you want to represent like a
some type or like a tree or something
like that things are gonna get a little
trickier the other problem we had was
where to make things symbolic and where
they always had to be concrete so we
knew we knew that the the polynomials we
were going to use your loops needed to
be fully unrolled by the time you get to
that so we decided that it didn't make
sense for your your matrices to have
symbolic shape that they had to have
concrete shape like we had to know that
they were a two by three matrix but the
elements could be symbolic so that was a
trade-off we made and that basically
comes up every time you want to support
some sort of structured data and one of
the side effects of doing this
compilation is some metadata and it's
this this problem I mentioned where you
know you only get introduced to work
with so somewhere else you have to store
like what was the structure and in this
case I call it metadata because in
general that's what it would be in the
specific case that we're working with it
would Julie it's very easy to like load
up some code and evaluate it so that's
actually what we do is we emit like a
function that says like how do you
reshape this list of integers that
you're gonna get from the circuit back
into the data you cared about so that it
becomes transparent to the user on both
ends both you know you just pass
arbitrary giulia values to the aichi and
you get back a giulia value from the
aichi that's what you see as a user
alright so how it all fits together this
is sort of our architectural diagram so
the this I guess this would be the left
this giulia system fheo jl is the
library we wrote in julia just a normal
julia library it doesn't hook into the
internals in any way
cept the part where we lower the code
and depend a little bit on the structure
of that but we didn't write like a C
extension or anything like that to Julia
so when you so I had that work flow
diagram before right so step one was
write your julia program so that happens
on the left here and then generating
your circuit and and your metadata
that's the that's this s expression
arrow that goes over to crucible and the
arrow that comes back is your circuit
and and that one will have the metadata
and then this next arrow that says
circuit plus input cipher text so that's
that's the step where you know you've
got your automatic circuit you've you've
julia has flattened out your your
structured data into lists or just one
list really and then we feed that all
over to palisade and the version of
house a that we used for this research
has a special like circuit interpreter
built on top of it and then that grind
battle would grind away and this bottom
arrow output ciphertext is that last
step where then it comes back into Julia
and then the crucible had output this
julia function for reshaping your data
and so then we would call that and you
get your data back and it would you know
it's like it never went anywhere except
there was a long wait in the middle
alright so I will I will check again if
there's any questions and but the next
part of the talk is I'm gonna go over
some of the things that we learned along
the way all right
oh hey how's that thank you
can the symbolic executor handle
programs that translate to exponential
or other transcendental functions so
it's a good question
I think if if you could unroll that into
a polynomial I think the answer is yes
transcendental functions
probably not we don't like the form of
division that we have it has to be the
last thing you do on a ciphertext and
you can only divide by powers of two so
some restrictions may apply does an H e
based algorithm expect all instances of
the same input to have the same
ciphertext if values include a non salt
can they still be analyzed I don't know
the answer to that one I'm not a
cryptographer all right next question
did you all consider using other methods
of secure computation that are more
performant than homomorphic encryption
yes oh so we when we were talking to I
ARPA they were specifically interested
in homomorphic encryption so for the
scope of this work we didn't at Galois
generally we we have had projects that
look at those other forms of secure
computation for sure I haven't worked on
those projects personally so I can't
really comment on the details so all
right next question is the integer
circuit itself also encrypted no it's
not the the integer circuit is is like
anybody can inspect that that's not part
of the the privacy all right
so I think I've kind of mentioned this
already so so Julia ended up being
really nice so I this is the what did we
learn so I hadn't used Julia prior to
this project so to me this is one of the
things we learned is hey Julia is great
for this because it's got reflection and
it's got macros and we used both of
those it's okay if you can't read this
slide the slide is basically just
showing you this is the API surface of
the library that we made in Julia and
all you need to take away from this is
we had a way to do key Jen we had a way
to encrypt and decrypt your values and
then we had a form of evaluation that
takes a function and its arguments and
we also had another
macro version of evaluations so that if
you wanted to be in a larger
computational context and just have like
the body of the loop do a chi every time
you go through the loop you could use
this macro version and it would just at
that point in the program when it needed
to do that part using a chi it would
just go through the workflow that I
described before for that expression so
there's of course no free lunches like
the one you'll have the day is already
paid for yeah so you can't always use
the algorithm you want you know the
question previously was about
transcendental functions you know good
luck with that because we don't have
general division we used one of our
early examples was doing something
statistical and I think it was linear
regression and we needed a determinate
function for that and you know the the
determinate functions that were sort of
built into things weren't suitable for
that either because they they used the
real numbers or something like that so
we use this thing this implementation of
the determinate the Richard bird who's a
functional programming researcher came
up with and this I don't expect you to
read this I mentioned earlier that maybe
maybe we used MATLAB a little bit in the
very beginning and the code the code on
the right is actually in MATLAB so you
know this code is in Julia but what I
want you to take away from this is the
short version that's naive determinate
very easy to write it's short it's
simple it's also something like n
factorial runtime the the other code is
an matlab implementation of richard
birds integer only determinate function
which is which is quite different like
if you look at them structurally it's
just like how are these even the same
computation and I I think Birds given
our implementation of matrix
multiplication is something like n to
the fourth so these n here is the size
of the you know these are square
matrices of size n by n so so
we kind of had this question once so we
couldn't get the naive determinate to
scale beyond about like 8x8 matrices so
we kind of were faced with this question
of like you know we want to use this
other one but is it the same well it
turns out that once you've done all this
stuff with symbolic evaluation and you
have this functional specification of
your of your computation on its inputs
then you can you can ask you can query
like these pretty advanced solvers like
SAS solvers and SMT solvers and it's
okay if you don't know what those terms
mean but they their logic solvers and
they're very powerful we can query them
and we can say given given this
functional spit specification of this
determinant on you know a 2 by 2 matrix
and this 1 on a 2 by 2 matrix where
what's the set of matrix values where
they disagree where they produce a
different result and if the solver comes
back and says that's the empty set then
we go great they produce the same output
on all values for 2x2 and so we did that
for sizes 2x2 up to 8x8 and and every
time the solver answered back their
computing the same thing like that sets
empty where they differ and so that was
good enough evidence for us for our
proof of concept to move on but I think
this is a general thing that people in
this room might want to know about is
that if if you if you are using
something I'll talk about it later we we
developed this thing called the software
analysis workbench if you're using the
MATLAB simulator that I'll show you
later if you're using any of these
things then you can you know you might
be able to prove equivalence of your
programs instead of testing alright so
another thing we ran into was at very
large circuits could be a problem so we
wrote all this code in Haskell which is
a fantastic language to program in and
sometimes it eats your heap and in our
case we're building up the circuit all
in memory all at once
and we ran out of heap and so we had to
switch to a streaming streaming way of
writing that out another thing that we
learned was symbolic loop constants can
be a lot of fun so this is greater this
common divisor just a very simple
recursive version of it you could write
it with a while loop and it'll have this
problems if a and B are symbolic inputs
it's very hard for the symbolic
executors to know when to stop
you can set upper bounds on this but
it's very hard to know to stop precisely
when you've computed the GCD and and
because of problems like this and the
reason it arises is because all of your
conditionals are on symbolic values so
programs that you want to to encode this
way through our compiler you want to
avoid that and you know this can be
tricky because maybe you refactor your
program and now you know it was working
and now it's not yeah so I already
mentioned equivalence proving is pretty
interesting sim D style parallelism
might become easier once you've done
this because the in our case since we're
getting out just an expression graph and
and in general you could get out
function calls or something and your
final value but we've specially picked
inputs that don't do that but if you get
out an expression graph like we did you
can do dataflow analysis on it very
easily one of the limitations of this
work is or sorry like the semantic
accuracy of what you're doing can be a
limitation so there's another symbolic
execution framework that's probably more
widely known named Klee and that one
doesn't follow all paths through the
program so it wouldn't have worked for
us because it would mean that some
inputs and your circuits just we
wouldn't know what to compute and
there's also the question of how well
did we match the the Julia
implementation when we re implemented
parts of it so we had to implement a
matrix multiplication inside crucible
and you know does it does it accurately
match what julia does is kind of a hard
question and yeah as a reminder we
didn't work on the performance problem
we worked on the usability problem
can-can normal programmers normal julia
programmers use a chi that was what we
were trying to address alright so I
mentioned these before so grackle is the
MATLAB symbolic interpreter the that we
developed saw as a software analysis
workbench it also uses crucible but in a
different way
saws for translating programs written in
languages like C or rust
I forget what what all languages we
support they're translating them into a
common representation and then allowing
you to reason about them so one of the
ways you might reason is the equivalence
checking that I mentioned before and
then if you're interested in the AG
palisade is pretty cool and that's
developed again by Kurt roll-off at New
Jersey Institute of Technology and I
think that's it
[Applause]